so we've been at comic con all weekend
and i've been super busy so i had no
time to bring out my girl
libby
jenna came up with a really great idea
like olivia the lobster and everything
was taken everywhere on social media so
we
well jenna said how about uh libby on
land
does that look real good good we have to
check out of the hotel first so i might
put some stuff on after
so we're trying to find ed uh but i
needed to have some carbs
before
before we start
he needs to back up
libby is starting to become
full effect hello
the most important thing when you're
going to go out and be
a libby what
what you're going to be living here
no i ain't got my face i can't i can't i
can't believe if i've got my face on
i got stage stuff yeah this is like
behind the scenes okay
libby doesn't eat meat
i eat meat what kind of vegetables just
eat
sea salads see cucumbers
no she likes she likes biscuits she
likes cheesy biscuits a lot right
because they're not going to get soggy
under water look at these on land
did you oh you should follow me on
twitter
does libby have a twitter account
i'm help help what is happening
a lot of things what is wrong
i don't know i'm asking you
is that what was wrong
is there something wrong back here
do you think it might be my my hair bun
do you think if
i were to be picked out of a tank
is that one good do you think that's
good all right i've got my badge
libby
let's go
how do i get to comic-con
i want direction of
goodness
i'm really sorry about this but i can't
take any requests right now please try
again in a little while
yeah i love lobster too
i
absolutely love
being on land because when i'm in the
sea this is something i don't do because
you just constantly are drinking
it's so refreshing because while i'm
swimming
i'm constantly
no no no no no no i got this i got to
get this
so to have this one single drink
and speechless
it tastes
so good
my hair fell off
okay that's good oh okay hello and no
one ever wants to shake my claws like hi
and there's like oh
that's like it's fine i'm not going to
pinch you
goodness
i haven't felt these heats since the
last time i almost got boiled
though
what do you want from me
what do you want from me i don't wait i
don't know what you want from me wait
wait you shot your mouth
wait shut your mouth
this is to be like a 15 it's going to be
an hour episode
oh my goodness
do you see it
holy sweet i'm so so sorry sir i'm so
sorry
hello i'll kiss you but already know
where those lips have been i'd go down
there for a while
it's okay
i'm a little shy
i didn't know that prostitution was
legal here
under the sea
everything goes except prostitution
what does that even mean